m
[Silence]
is
him
[Silence]
is
i'd to start out this session
tonight
this latest installment of
by mentioning something very important
something that i believe is necessary to
mention
and that is that
a lot of people know ibn al-qayyim
but they really don't know ibn al-qayim
rahimahullah
they know ibn al-qayyim
for some of his works
the prophet's medicine
al-ma'ad for those who are more
more versed
they know abnor
for some of his treaties on
the ailments of the heart
and
the correction of these of said ailments
and they know ibn al-qayyim for other
books
such as madeira jessely
and his book nuniya which is about six
thousand verse long
poem
which
at the very end he
has a very in-depth
vivid description of paradise which is
very popular
amongst people and has been
translated into many languages and
reviewed and
memorized and explained
and he has other books that many of us
are aware of
but there is a
chasm in understanding who abn was
allah
with regards to his position and his
time
is one link of a chain
of a group of scholars that
swept the muslim world at that time
and revived
much of the
the
sunnah of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam in a time of darkness for the
muslims when i say darkness i mean a
time of darkness
with regards to knowing their religion
a time when
the people of
greek philosophy and roman philosophy
and many logicians as they caught refer
to themselves
and many innovations had been introduced
into the belief system of the muslim
and so ibn al-qaeda is one of the
great scholars that wrote many many many
books
refuting much of this and reviving the
sunnah of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam this being one of them
but often times we find
that many people wish to pluck ibn
al-qaeda
out
from amongst the rest of his
his colleagues and his peers
of scholars during that time
is inseparable
from evan
islam
is inseparable
the reason for that is that most of ibn
tamiya's works are preserved and
presented and explained and elaborated
on by ibm
rahimahullah when we look at ibn kayim's
works
we see that they revolve around the
works of ibn tamiya
and the best person that has explained
the works and ideas
of ibn taymiyyah was his student
and he was his most dutiful
and devout student
so they are inseparable
but there was a group of scholars at
that time
such as
allah the great muhaddith
ibn kathir's
father-in-law
likewise
is
we have
shem sadina zahabi
who was a great muhaddith
and these are groundbreaking scholars
when i mean groundbreaking
they are from a
particular breed of scholars that are
referred to
in the books of philip and referred to
in the books of tafsir as
means that they study and research every
topic to death
until they absolutely reach the core end
of it
and
are able to substantiate the position in
unwavering terms
these group of scholars are referred to
as
one of these types of people al-imam
tabari
the four imams as well
they are considered
likewise we have a group such as
such as
sheikh islamiyah ibn khayem even
cathedral
right and they were from all different
schools of thoughts i mean even even
cathedral
right
but they all followed the same
path
when it came to the issue of akida when
it came to the issue of belief and to
heed and innovation
and that is
that
not just with regards to the worship of
allah alone without any partners but how
we understand
the names and attributes of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala and the names and
attributes of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
are understood in the following way
there are four principles mentioned by
al-imam malik
that i will share with you okay
so
[Silence]
foreign
and so the principle
of ibn al-qayyim of eventemia the
principle of
the scot these scholars
if you read it right
the principle is as follows
with regards to the names and attributes
of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala with
regards to the actions of allah
they follow thee
methodology and the understanding of the
companions of the prophet salallahu
it's not enough to merely believe
in the quran and sunnah you have to
believe in the quran in sunnah in the
way that allah intended that you believe
in the quran in sunnah
right
he said amen
said
i believe in allah
and whatever has come to us from allah
in the way
that allah intended that i believe in it
and i believe in the messenger of allah
and i believe
all of that which has come to us from
the messenger of allah in the way that
the messenger of allah intended
and so it's not enough for a person to
merely believe in the quran in sunnah
there are many interpretations to the
quran in sunnah correct we see that
you can you can literally find anything
you want in the quran in sunnah and
understand them any way you want
but there's only one correct
understanding
right
what is that understanding
is
[Silence]
so how is it that a person understands
the quran and sunnah there are many
interpretations to the quran in sunnah
we understand the quran in sunnah
as allah subhanahu wa ta'ala instructed
when he said in surat al-baqarah
if they believe meaning the non-muslims
if they believe
in that
which you all have believed in the way
that you all have believed then they
will become guided
speaking about who
speaking about
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and his companions
so in order for us to become guided
we have to believe
in the way that
the messenger and his companions
believed
right
and we stopped where they stopped
we stopped where they where they stopped
we don't go past that
and so
this kind of reminds me of a statement
of alibi talib
[Silence]
yes
and so this reminds us of a statement
when he said
all of the knowledge that we have been
given is really just a drop one drop
that's it
that's all we've been given
but the ignorant people
they have
expanded this drop
right they have expanded this drop what
does that mean they have expanded this
drop
when somebody who is not qualified to
speak
on a matter of the quran in sunnah
speaks and interprets the quran and
sunnah in his own way
now there has to be
an element of research and review and
refutation
in order to
right that wrong
and so books become more and more
voluminous
knowledge becomes more and more we have
to have more debates more issues come up
and so
knowledge is not as accessible anymore
as it once was
there is more information than is
actually required
so
what is the understanding of imam malik
a man came to imam malik and he asked
him he said
rose above the throne
how did he rise above the throne
he rose above the throne as allah tells
us in the quran correct
this man doesn't does is not suffice
with that he wants to know how he rose
above the throne
so imam malik
he said
rising above the throne this statement
el istiwe
that action
is known what it means its definition
its diction that diction is understood
when we say it's rose above the throne
it's clear what is meant by that
in linguistically
he said but
how he rose above the throne is
unfathomable
something that the human being cannot
cannot fathom
and belief in that concept
that
fact is obligatory because it is in the
quran in no uncertain terms
and asking about it
asking about how allah rose above the
throne is a type of innovation
why is it an innovation
because the companions
did not ask that question
if we look in the quran we see that that
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was asked many questions
he was even asked about menstruation
correct in surah
a man
having relations with his wife during
her menstrual cycle
they even asked about that
but never in the quran do you find that
they ask questions about
how allah's names or how allah's
attributes are never why because they
understood the
greatness of allah
and that's what we have been given in
the quran in sunnah is the limit of what
our minds can fathom
what we have been given i will repeat
that
what we have been given
of knowledge about allah
in the quran in sunnah
is the limit in this world
of what our minds can fathom about allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala and his names and
attributes
that is all that we need in order to
reach allah and reach our full potential
no more knowledge
is necessary to reach our full potential
we have not left out anything that is
necessary from the book allah subhanahu
wa says
so we are sufficed with what allah has
told us about himself
we don't start asking questions
about how allah does what he does
okay
this is not part of our belief system
when we start to ask these questions
and when we start to look for their
answers and someone who is untrained in
the quran and sunnah begins to formulate
and postulate hypotheses on the answers
to these questions this is where
innovation comes from
right so when we think about
plato aristotle
many of these
philosophers
when you read their books of philosophy
you see that
they have
maybe an ounce of truth and a pound of
half truths and misguidance
because they were not prophets they were
trying to
reach
and understand the reality of this world
and who allah is and why we are
through
through logic alone and the unbridled
mind is a dangerous place
it's a very dangerous place
right
and so
even the truths that are found
in
philosophy
they are truths
that are reached and arrived at
conclusions that are arrived at in the
most difficult way possible
it's if you said
i want you to touch your ear
so you you touch your ear this
now
instead of just touching your ear like
this you touch it the long way
so even the truths that are found in
these
works of these philosophers these
greeks and romans and in in hindu and
and so forth these philosophers the the
small amount of truth that was found in
their works
is reached and arrived at in the most
difficult way possible
there are aspects of
philosophy that are so hard to
understand and comprehend
that some of the most intelligent people
are unable to understand it
because it is full of rhetoric and
sophistry
right
and so
the point here is that we do not go
beyond
the quran and sunnah
this is the way of the companions of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
this is the revival that took place in
the time of ibn al-qaeda
and so if we want to separate ibn
al-qayyam from ibn taymiyyah you cannot
do that
and that's something that a lot of
people try to do
because even tell me
allah was more blunt
and he was more
he was more
blunt and more
straightforward and more
aggressive in his approach
to debating these issues
and he suffered dearly because of that
approach
he was put in jail and he died in jail
actually he was beat he was whipped he
was
his books were bought and purchased by
people just to burn them
in his time
because they didn't have printing
presses now
you know if you take this book and burn
it we have a million other copies no
you he would write it by hand and then
other people would have to write it
again by hand
so there's only a dozen copies they
would try to gather all those copies and
burn them just to get rid of them this
is what ibn al-qaeda
evan taimiya endured and ibrahim as well
and even kathie as well many people
don't know that
right
so we don't go beyond the quran and
sunnah we don't ask questions that
the companions didn't ask
so for example
there's a narration in sahih muslim in
which the prophet
salallahu said
in allah
[Silence]
so there's a narration for instance
in sahih muslim in which the prophet
salallahu wasallam says
allah
allah descends every last third of the
night
to the
lower heaven of the dunya
and he says is there anyone asking me so
that i may give him is there anyone who
is
seeking my forgiveness that i may
forgive him is there anyone
supplicating to me that i may answer his
supplication this narration is authentic
and collected by imam muslim
now
do we ask how does allah descend no
we say dissension is understood what it
means linguistically
and how he descends is unfathomable
the fact that you would ask that
question articulates that you do not
understand the greatness of allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
the fact that you would
question
how allah does what he does
this articulates that you have not
understood the grandeur of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
because one who has understood the
greatness and grandeur of allah will not
ask these questions because he
understands that allah is beyond
the realm of
understanding how
he is
what is how
how is when we take something that we
know and we compare something else to it
how are you going to do that with allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
he is absolutely incomparable
to anything
in every single way
[Arabic recitation]
he has no beginning he has no end he
knows everything he is the one he has no
one who has brought him into existence
subhanahu wa'ta'ala he brings no one
else similar to him into existence there
is none him in any way
right
and so
what this means is that
if we recite
allah
and we understand this verse properly
these verses
we will never ask silly questions like
this
so a person would say well wait a minute
the earth is round and the last third of
the night is constantly moving and so
how is it that allah that means that
this is a problem for human beings this
is not a problem for allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
right
this is a problem this is an issue
for the creation this is not an issue
for the creator
we understand that yes allah descends
and he is there to
to be asked so what do we understand
from this get up in the last third of
the night and make dua that's it that's
what we understand
we don't go beyond that
and if you want to rest all of your
beliefs on how how how
you will be very weak in belief because
the mind is not it has limits and there
are issues which are super irrational
they are beyond the realm of
the limitations of the human mind
so we have to understand these issues
with regards to
with regards to the tahiti of allah
this is all an explanation and i've
taken this as an opportunity
to in the past four lectures or so
as an opportunity to explain and
describe
the talheed of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
we've spoken about shirk we've spoken
about tawheed we've spoken about the
types of tohit we've spoken about the
types of shirk we've spoken about
major and minor shirk major and minor
fulham major and minor fusuok etc we've
spoken about all of these things
and this now is kind of a crown on all
of that
the names and attributes of allah and
the actions of allah how we are to
understand these names and attributes of
allah we do not ever go past what is
given to us in the quran in sunnah
this doesn't mean that we don't ask
about the meanings
right if you don't understand the
meaning of something then that is
something to ask about
but if you are asking about how
if you are asking about
the
essence of how allah does what he
does that is that is a red line you
don't cross that line
that goes back to amen
we believe in it because it is all come
to us from allah subhanahu wa
so i will share with you a verse from
the quran
in
and i hope that everyone tonight has
understood
what we have spoken about with regards
to
how we
receive
the names and attributes of allah
how do we receive the names and
attributes of allah with pure belief
right
if we don't understand the meaning
yani is
[Silence]
so for example with regards to the
meaning yes we ask about the meaning
if you don't understand the meaning of
something by all means please ask about
it
but do not ask about
the
interpretation or the
the how of these
actions of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
do not ask those questions
because those questions are unfathomable
to you anyways
and if i say to you that
allah wa'ta'ala created the heavens and
the earth he created something from
nothing
right and this something that he created
from nothing is not a part of him
how are you going to understand how that
occurred
that is an impossibility this is what we
call super irrational
right
the mind cannot fathom such a thing
and to try to find answers for this
thing
is is is exactly how a person will go
astray with regards to the names and
attributes of allah subhanahu wa
because allah began his book by saying
those who believe in the unseen
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala is the epitome
of the unseen
we do not understand how allah subhanahu
we understand that he is
but we do not understand how he is
and so if we want to ask about the
meaning of something by all means ask
you hear the name of allah
what is the difference between
and
they have the same root word and the
similar etymology yet what is the
difference between them ask this
question this is a very good question
ask what is the meaning of the name of
allah al-muhamen what is the meaning of
the name of allah al-jabbar
al-mu'min what does this mean
ask those questions yes
but do not ask how does allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala know everything how does allah
rise above the throne how does allah
descend
to thee lower heaven how does
do allah ask these questions these
questions are innovative in nature and
they will only lead you to
misguidance
the prophet salallahu
[Silence]
on
foreign